six one seven eight three zero 4750
let's go to our next caller from the 202
area code caller from 202 tell us who
you are and you can jump right in to
your question my name is Jay I was
wondering if the collusion situation
would that lead to deeper situations
such as money laundering and things of
that nature
I mean the answer is basically yes that
so the as Rudy Giuliani now has decided
to point out at any opportunity it's not
even clear that collusion is a crime so
when what we're talking about is a
number of possible crimes that work that
were committed right and this can
include money laundering campaigns fine
at finance violations obstruction of
justice witness tampering is so on and
so forth as many on the right will be
quick to tell you the collusion it's in
and of itself is not a crime but when we
talk colloquially about colluding with a
foreign power for the benefit of a
domestic election particular candidate
in a domestic election there's a whole
bunch of crimes that could be there so
it's not so much that like money
laundering would be deeper than
collusion it might be one of the actual
underlying crimes that is part of the
broader collusion okay okay yeah well
yeah no problemo appreciate the call six
one seven eight three zero forty seven
fifty what's going on today Pat
something something is just up today
yeah I was worried that this live call
segment was going off the rails yeah I
think that last caller for vindicating
it put it back on track